all right welcome back to raft yeah a
game we've never played before hey guys
why we're starting in a brand new world
there's been a new update now the game's
finished so we're starting over again
because our files are all probably
corrupt don't tell them things what do
you mean not tell them things they're
listening to the things shut shut their
ears mark yeah
or something cut their ears and suck
their mouths wow suck go suck
yourself i'm not gonna suck anyone's
mouth go suck i would never you can't
make me i'd like to see me try i would
too like to see me you try how about
this take that now we have an audi
what's an audi hey
oh [ __ ] oh
oh it's this one little thing i made a
hammer so i can do stuff well i suppose
i was trying to get a hammer so i should
probably not do that anymore and do
something else
you don't have hammers okay i'll make a
hammer then [ __ ] with me okay
how are we gonna steer to the land
jackass it's straight ahead of us
jackass we are we are kind of headed
right here jackass all right jackass
what do you what do you mean
[ __ ]
get out of here i will not
oh this is your chance
never mind
all right yeah that island's getting
kind of close
i feel like we guys the shark is here
what
sure
there is guys remember there's a shark
in this game yeah apparently there's
other fish creatures too yeah we
encountered one didn't we wasn't there
uh uh bloat fish
no no there's more there's like a big
there's bigs oh what is that big
you know bigs like the company bigs
no
no
stop that's the problem what do we do
about that
well that was your fault
i love my life i need that i'm trying to
accumulate ropes
well me too i also need ropes
well are you going to be in charge of
fishing or what we're not we're all
pulling the same weights here until we
get no no no no we need oh
god uh and i was the chef last time i
think this is gonna be like well we
generalize until we specialize right
bye mark i'm okay i guess we go right
i mean we don't even really we can only
harvest stuff we can grab ooh there's
now crates in addition to barrels so
that's cool dude i love crate and barrel
dude grain barrel here's a question how
do we get our raft off of the island
paddle
my bro uh do we have one of those
i don't know
maybe i think we
lost that already i think we lost we
lost what do you mean we lost i can't
make a paddle
we'll make a pat wait what i don't have
a recipe for a paddle is the right to do
um i'm an idiot i'm a dude
actually stuck on the island are we good
uh it's under navigation that's where
paddle is it kind of makes sense that
was not the answer to your question bob
but yeah no i'm i got it i figured i saw
i answered my own question we're going
to get cool why is your name wayne
sevens what happened
i have a last name what do you mean
don't you guys have last names [ __ ]
you're the weird ones all right man
whatever you use either of you have six
plastics uh probably i'm currently dying
to a shark so we'll see okay ow bro
bro coming to save you trying to collect
these rocks bro
oh yeah i forgot rocks are important
rocks are important rocks are important
so it's not drowning apparently uh how
many plastics i have seven
okay yeah i need
one of them
all right buddy have fun
you are you winning son nope wait guys
we're going out of the secret underwater
cave to drown in
the shark can come in here
oh i'm super dead uh i'm gonna try and
come somewhere where you could uh bring
me back to the boat and make a bed so i
can live i would love if you would come
there are you alive did you die
i died on the edge of the raft i forgot
about oxygen you only lose two thirds of
your inventory if you die isn't it isn't
that different than it used to be i
don't know maybe
mayhaps oh oh hey what's up bob we'll
get i know that's why i'm you should
make one
look out everybody
oh you are dead okay
um why are you dead yeah um simple bed
ten palm leaves six legs four plastic
three nails
um the bed oh my god i have five no no
that isn't bedroll an option bed roll
bedroll bed roll bed roll better there's
like a it's like a leaves
it's just bed roll there's a rug i could
make a rug
if that's
like
i think simple bed is what you're
talking about simple bed is it i have
ten
uh palm leaves here
taking your resources i've got two nails
i've got nails i don't have nails you
got enough nails okay save me why did
you die for palm leaves
okay i got those here hold on what do
you need plastic here's four palm leaves
three planks for plastic okay i don't
have the palm leaves
here really doesn't seem like my fault
uh here's the plastic
okay here's the planks
um palm leaves
four of them
that they're gotta be close by you can
tell can we get them off of those trees
i think if we had an axe axe to harvest
them free god bob why did you die do we
have to start over again wait stone axe
i can make it i got a guy i got a stone
axe you save it for the bed here i go
just come on just
come on
you're the one that died okay how many
more palm leaves did you need
four okay i have four here i'm gonna
chuck four down where are you wait wait
it's busy dying into the shark oh i'm
feeling great
it's coming down catch
okay
go into the water it's going it way in
the water it's way in the water did you
see it
i caught it finally thanks
yeah you're welcome yeah wait you should
have gotten that done sooner man
water collector purifier those would be
good things to get we got fruit
i can make a grill i can make a grill we
need six palm leaves and i have what we
need for a water purifier maybe that's
more important there's one more tree i
might be able to give them enough palm
leaves
i'm not 100 i'm going to make the grill
and maybe the fishing room i don't have
the rope to make a fishing rod i need
four more ropes you don't happen to have
any ropes on you do you mark no you have
uh i do actually i think i might be able
to help and you toss down two ropes sir
coming
all right here's some ropes
law
oh yeah
all right i have one coconut
here's a coco nut and here's three beets
i slightly lied i need more i do i
didn't realize you need a rope for the
fishing rod and also for the grill
i'm gonna make the fishing rod and and
start catching fish and then we'll get
more once we start
oh
[Applause]
this is the worst start we've ever had
you don't know that many times we've
played this how have you ever done this
to us just go get some
oh there's a tree on the back of the
island i missed okay we're in business
all right got the palm leaves i just
need two more come on baby oh no anybody
got any rope
oh you know what i got 10 rope right in
my inventory
no okay actually uh i did get enough
rope so i made a paddle so we're good
here oh let's get the hell out of this
godforsaken place all right
we're this island provided and we had
just enough
let us away
it proved
the
raft the next thing we need is some some
cups
and some um what you call it a thingy
water
purifier
water
[Music]
i got the black right now
we need some palm leaves for the water
purifier okay let me turn the boat we're
a little crooked i think if i
will we turn if i just oh i don't know
we'll pick up the bat i'm picking up the
bed oh no wait it's gone
it's kind of thingy i thought i thought
the best
i will say i need to repair that as fast
as possible because if that breaks i
think the bed will go bye-bye i
need six planks and then i can make the
water purifier but then read
then we need more plastics
and or if you can make yourself a cup
that's fine with everyone we need to we
need cups
sharing cups is kind of a pain in the
ass roger i need two more plonkos i'm
just gonna um get this
so brave one so brave
brave or stupid
what's the difference
because yeah
i'm making a simple purifier
yes nice excellent i'm putting the
purifier down in the right here area yes
good excellent and i need one more
plastic to make a cup because i'm dying
of thirst how do we turn it out i don't
know
you mean like a rotate the boat yeah
because we rotated when we went around
the mount um the island but it doesn't
seem like we're turning
unless i get out and like push on the
one end the water's deep
is this pushing is this pushing i'm
gonna i'm gonna start with the water
cooking
yeah
i'm gonna go down like a second oh god
take it then because i'm full health
when that water's done you take it
feeling okay man
yes now i drink all right welcome back
to raft okay we we have a chance now how
are you doing mark i'm fine thirsty you
hungy no i miss that barrel i'm kind of
sad big boy
whoa wrapped on the left
do you have a cup mark uh not yet but i
will make one
short
one more plastic i can make it you watch
i got a cup i'm i'm sleeping yeah oops
all right i'm gonna try to go towards
that raft i'm gonna keep uh cucumber
cooking us towards this uh other raft
over here
no it's nice nice we're gonna
cannibalize it can we cannibalize it i
wish you could just slang your raft
right on that bad boy i wish i wish we
could rotate our raft i freaking wish
dude yeah we got all twisty turvied from
that first island
raft
all right who's going aboard
uh
i'll try to keep probably not paddle man
yeah yeah
whoa what the hell that was it i got the
the one thing it is thinking it's
sinking it's sinking
um i've got a blueprint for antenna and
receiver
uh-huh i've got a raw beat one incoming
incoming incoming
incoming
hey all right that one's gotta be close
to dead god i forgot how hard like the
first one is that um
the thing where you like look down and
and look up at the horizon on the edge
of your screen you can kind of see it oh
yeah
i'm looking all right cool i'll start
paddling when we get closer
what what guys
whale kill the shark oh i thought the
shark was about to attack the whale i
was going to be most as well or those
crates yep mark's getting them i got
them double crate oh god i didn't carry
all the there's beets and ropes and
stuff oh i got it i got let me i think
we need some containers now because
otherwise we're going to be
dude low-level containers are garbo
though i know but we have nothing else
oh they take so much
hey
i just filled my cup with saltwater the
exciting way all right i'm gonna need
food but i've expanded our boat to where
our bed and our [ __ ] should be safe our
bed
towards you yeah yeah
how's your paddle
uh it's about to break but i think i'll
be able to make another one oh is that
the sound of you sucking net hooking he
really sucks at hooking terrible hooker
terrible hooker worst hooker ever oh i
got an award for that oh my hook broke
i've been even worse okay
all right i could make one hold on hold
on we're oh
[Applause]
okay all right here we go
hey i've got an anchor you can get us
over there yeah i'll get us over there
oh hungary
the guy with the paddle is the one
telling us to stop hey man
i was just asking i wasn't telling i
ain't the captain around here are we
captainless for now till we hold a vote
the first vote
are you
maidenless
and then every uh every episode of this
will vote for a new captain
the previous captain will assign captain
points and then throughout the episode
at the end of it we'll declare a captain
winner and then they will be the captain
completely fair very impartial very
impartial when you say when you add very
to it like that it just makes me want to
believe you thank you that's why i said
it when you say thank you like that it
just makes me not want to believe you uh
screw you
uh you got me back you got me back
oh so hungry
i
there hopefully is a fish on the grill
you can have no i'm gonna get some of
these cocoa nuts
oh coco nuts
okay dane cook i wonder how he's doing
how's he doing he's i don't know but
he's doing like live streams on tick
tock or something that's great for him
i'm really proud of him i love that for
hot drowning
oh
man the drowning is so subtle well i
drowned in real life it's way more
dramatic and noticeable
you know what i bet i bet you use more
water and food when you sprint and i bet
if you walk
you use way less
that's so boring though that's my theory
though
i really like
that the the drowning is so casual the
first time i freaked out it's because my
bar went all the way down to zero but i
forgot
not having any errors not a big deal you
got like 30 seconds before anything that
happens
that's a bad it's a bad it's hard
what you need to make a new one you good
eight planks and three ropes i sure
don't i got probably some of the oh hey
the sharks over here i'm in the middle
of the ocean and the circus here oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna die again guys
i don't know the song is pretty funny
man the song is making it sound very fun
but it's kind of serious
it's a real catch real catchy would you
like some blue seeds uh i'll keep i'll
hold on to the seeds because i'm
collecting them
um so uh
that way when we have bees and whatnot
i need eight rope and two plonks okay i
got you on the planks these four planks
here is a rope here's palm fronds and a
rope
i don't need rope i have a whole ass
load of palm prawns i'm an idiot never
mind i'll take it back thank you though
thank you thank you thank you of course
we're here together a team
a family
all right i've got i've got a fishing
rod more speeds oh sure i'll take
i'll be in charge of horticulture
you're a holder holder holder cartridge
holy crap what is that word i'm saying
no you got a pork culture
yeah you gotta get moving so we get more
wood
all just need more wood
uh how does this anchor work
you touch it and it like detaches and
we're free basically
do i get to recollect the anchor no it's
just it's just consumable it goes away
okay
all right
anybody need water what do you want to
drink this wawa
uh i'm good no did someone pick my beat
or did my beat get seagulled uh i
probably got seagulled yeah
i can play with all their better ones
that's mark's job anyway shark shark is
coming jerk
wait save me
did it research i can't repair the boat
though because i'm out of wood i'm
researching
i'm gonna
i can repair the boat i think oh who
pushed me
who pushed me i squeeze
why are you pushing me
there we go all right why are you
pushing me i am not pushing you that way
why would you push me
i am resuming the fish
oh hey a raft straight ahead oh paddle
boy
what where we might be heading toward it
naturally we kind of actually we are
just going to do it yeah
oh hey research
i have research to do i have a
clam what boom big clam baby
researched
adjust of course come on idle boy one
moment
must get barrel
look better oh nice nice nice nice nice
all right so how do we
how do we earn
captain points
uh i think some discussion of this i'm
just not clear on how this works i'm not
sure maybe i should get the random
number generator out oh yeah that always
works out well for me
i'll put a random wheel of like who
is going to get points and then who
earns points but uh well i won't be in
charge of uh the other boat it's
approaching fast so someone else get
ready to go because it's about time i
will i will do this i'm starving to
death is there food i have it there is
one on the grill cooking should
be uh that's the end of that
there was one box too bad i can't take
any of the rest of the wood or metal
that that thing is clearly made of okay
i've got a wheel okay i'm gonna spin the
wheel okay
let's see let's click to spin bam
spinning the wheel mark
really i
i swear
i'm putting it in the discord it is
whatever yeah no you didn't just draw
that oh yeah that's fine uh-huh it's
what it means
ms paint image of an arrow pointing at
mark all right i'm rolling the number of
points i get oh
nine captain
oh sure no yeah nine seems likely that
seems likely it's what it was my guys
hey there's barrels that no one is
cooking i said that i was busy all right
i don't think research is more important
than barrels i just want to throw that
out we just unlocked a bunch of things
all right guys good and what do you need
to make them
probably better the barrel stuff
yeah
yeah that's a
don't worry i'll research
learn learn learn learn learn learn
learn learn
learn hey guys guess what i got what do
you got barrels full of stuff oh wet
brick wow
yeah i know right
that's incredible all right but what did
we get uh collection nets that's helpful
lantern lantern all right
and we can see our incompetence in hd
croplets
[Music]
whoa
you're all right man
okay
i'm hungry uh here uh uh
doing i'm hungry too thanks uh here you
ink
thank you
wait if you want your food it's on the
floor
it might fall into the ocean at any
moment careful attack
got it man i should make a spear uh what
are we lowest on right now i've got nine
plastic 14 planks i got i'm low on
planks i got that i got planks who wants
planks planks going on the ground what
is 20 planks what is this that i have oh
i have a package guys oh inside of my
package i learned chairs oh wait i have
no clearly a chair
i'm opening my
package i got a shelf that's so hot wow
i don't have a package wow that's the
money somebody drink this water boys uh
land to the right left to the right
drank water you guys see the land to our
right uh how right
uh yeah i'm facing right i don't know if
we can paddle there that's directly to
the right that's gonna take a lot of
paddle
right i mean i can try but i was like
somebody's a piece of being lazy well i
mean look at all this useful items right
here in the ocean
you know what you know what i'll show
you soon in the great pacific trash pile
yeah
i hate raw fish ah why would you do that
oh because my thingies is on the wrong
buttons whoopsies look at all this good
[ __ ]
yeah just wait we're gonna have more
good [ __ ] soon in a moment
let's try which one do you want to
expand
we're gonna go sideways right
should yeah we should make a rectangle
and have a sort of a wide side so that
when we can actually turn the boat we
can
okay which way you want me to go wide
with right or left first don't matter uh
continue in the longest way we currently
have is it four by four
then just widen it in the way that's
beneficial for where we're going right
now and that'll be fine i'm gonna remove
the the
research table until we need it again
let's see like efficiency and then i'm
gonna put right there
and right there
so we can start crop plotting and then
we actually have a whole [ __ ] ass of
planks also uh here mark
the beets are for you for the planting
thank you there you are
that will get us started on that
baby we're going to get some watermelon
and some uh
water one watermelon
[ __ ] yeah someone watermelon i love it
hey mark i got a package i got a
mosquito for you merc well i'm gonna put
another uh potato i'm gonna put another
uh water purifier right there if that's
okay with you
i learned roses oh is it time to spin
the wheel of captain uh uh probably
totally fair very fair very fair
spinning it again go there
da da
all right baby yeah you guys want
screenshots every time no
you know what i trust you buddy okay
random amount of captain points going to
bob is
six
all right that's not bad
i earned that good or extra bad that's
uh extra good
six is bloody he's like points who just
died
hi no one died oh
water did water used to do the whole
croplet before did you didn't you used
to have no you have to water each mound
oh it's it's better now it does the
whole croplet oh sick
maybe i'm not remember that correctly
but no i feel like that's novel and new
and very good
design decisions by the game makers look
at all those barrels i don't know if
this is going to hit that one but yeah
we get a lot of no you got it bro you
got it you got it bro and i got this one
bro
oh my god bro bro
i'm the leader
oh no i already caught a catfish is that
bad oh yeah you need that you need the
big thing to cook them
uh have we researched the bigger grill
yet or do we need something like that
let me look let me look man i'm hungry
uh nope
wait don't look behind you you'll get so
scared
i'm not scared of anything
oh i'm gonna make
a food chest okay
chest
refugees
did you eat both of those fish weighed
yeah the ones you threw at me i did one
where's my mark oh
unbelievable unbelievable
oh there's an island coming up i don't
see it now but it was like up to the
left i think mark i have a dry block
yeah i see it okay we could research oh
yeah let me plop down yield research
table all right you want to go towards
that island yeah as well yes i think
we're doing decent on materials right
now all right sounds we can learn
smelter lads lads that's good i think
that's one of the first steps toward
getting the better grill isn't it metal
ingot is the last thing we need for the
grill so yeah we need to smelt
did you kill it
no no i was trying to get those barrels
before we left but i did not that's okay
it's okay um what do we need food
hi mark did you push me did you push me
did you push me literally stood where i
am and watched you did you push me
do [ __ ] tv okay i have all the nails we
need for the smelter i just don't have
the dry blocks
[Music]
i just researched away the only one so
we just need more clay never mind sand
okay i've got one clay i can serve as a
distraction for the shark as you guys
dive deep into the murky depths of death
we should be close to killing it i've
been stabbing that for a while look at
all the lures there we go
[Music]
no no no scarecrow you blocked me they
wouldn't have an anchor wait the shark's
dead
kill it maybe kill it i need four ropes
to make an anchor i can get you guys
right there on the ground well i've got
all the shark meat to cook now good good
that's nice well i just need one of them
big o's actually you can cook i think
one shark meat on the regular okay we're
stuffed i need to re-plot
some uh
these things now's a great time to focus
on the underwater stuff when the sharks
dead yeah you're right he's right the
wisdom he's
true you know what he is right let me
know if you guys find another watermelon
up there we're going to have we're going
to be eating good if you do
nobody is on the island so all right i'm
going to the island i'm gonna go look
for another uh watermelon on that island
do we have any more food somewhere
because i'm starving to death again uh i
got some beets that i like slowly but
surely uh food production is ramping up
and i can cut down some of these trees
for more real quick
broke
give me a moment you guys are hungry
boys tell you what that's cause you guys
are running around like crazy
oh that drowning thing it sure sneaks up
on you yeah it's big ouches
shark is back be aware shark is back
shark is alive and back
very back very alive
oh not in the oxygen thing again
and the shark really is just not coming
over here which is
yeah you seem good so far he's really
sticking by the boat you guys are okay
i say with full confidence
and food and water sure sneak up on you
just like breathing while you are
swimming it's an extremely intensive
exercise
swimming 50 feet down to the ocean floor
is exertion uh you know in some circles
poppy dick
i agree
that was a cheap laugh you shouldn't
have laughed at that oh no you make me
laugh man you make me laugh
yeah and you guys got stone i need uh i
need to make an axe to go back on the
island and i need to get a bunch of
stuff in my head
if you got one stone i would love you
forever
i'm at the raft and i've got your stone
slowly because i'm dying of dehydration
there's a water ready there and then
there's a fish in the tub
all right oh god that shark is uh well
i don't know if you saw that but i think
i might be going uh getting the c
madness here you getting the ocean
crazies yeah
how do i drop just one right click it
out right right click drag it out
and now it's time to spin the wheel of
captain
who's gonna be the next person to get
captain points
[Music]
i'm shocked i
scared me me me who gets the points
and seems just like that episode of
distractible that you all should go
listen to distractible surely the people
listening to this have heard of
distractible how could they not right
they haven't are they even human are
they even human
human
what side are you on bob
i thought you liked that bit i do that's
like your favorite bit it's like one of
my favorite bits it's a good bit put
down some
wet bricks how many you make yeah four
okay i can make the other four and i've
got uh two
three more clay if you need it
yeah
let's jump attack
go away i got i made a spear whoa get
out of here seagull that's eight that's
all we needed was eight right is this
the food chest are we only putting food
in here
it can be whatever but i made it to be a
food chest yeah i think i think for
enough food's good there we have three
ropes so i can make another grill yep
yeah here
no i got it no i got it oh here it's on
there no oh no mine oh it's right there
i'm good thanks oh okay
i'll take them all that's fine uh do we
need more sand and clay for stuff bob i
see we just release anchor and then we
go oh well that's an old bid okay tired
bit even fine then
fine abandoning our cohort would be
heartless
and juvenile yeah also there's still a
shark yourself a captain uh well i'm not
a captain yet i don't know you want to
spill in the wheel of captain again
all right we're spinning the wheel of
captain
all right
[Music]
all right shall we cast off uh
yeah if we're done trying to get metal
and sand and clay then yes i mean
there's a shark here so i think we can
go i think
we got we got what we need from now from
this island we can just kind of all
right coast and see what we get all
right sounds good so when do we make the
decision of who's captain when do we end
this this uh uh i don't know this feels
like a pretty good start
all right then should i
how do we do we call this and and do
like a captain rotation i'll do one more
winner that'll make it fair like one
more
[Applause]
one more spinny and that could change
everything because one of you guys could
get more points than me it could win
it's fair right yeah all right one more
squeeze
spinning again
[Music]
this could take
all the beans this could
all the beans how many points does he
get
five
that's a lot of points total that's more
than five and with bob at six points
weighted 11 points and me at
14 points okay i
will be capped
in the next
hour
of this adventure
[Music]
bye